when you were first having kids rick
were you was did you go through like a
panic state yeah of course it's it's
everyone goes through the same process
right you don't want you
you you almost fear yourself out of
having them and then i mean we watched
it happen with our guitar player like
one year before he's telling me like i'm
just not meant to have kids man and
ain't in my cars i don't want him blah
blah you know like
the whole speech and i'm like i don't
know man like when you i told him i said
when you have a kid
you're going to think your kid's the
greatest it's all you're going to talk
about i don't think so
if i called him right now i'd be like
what are you doing he's like hanging on
my little buddy he's the greatest man
you gotta see him he's already pl dude
he's already playing stairway to heaven
on the guitar he's one you know like
like you you
like you said the the best sperm gets
into the door right so you're proud
you're pumped and and i uh you know what
luke you were saying i think that that
it's in it's in our it's embedded in
women it's embedded in us to have this
this
you know nature this this motherly
nature this fatherly instinct